so we finally got an actual press briefing from
White House Press Secretary Secretary Kayleigh
McEnany yesterday. And, of course, with Donald
Trump having answered questions only once in the
month, really in the six weeks, two weeks before
and month since the election, there were many
important issues that reporters had for the White
House and they finally got an opportunity to ask
these questions of Kayleigh McEnany. Now, it was
absolutely the stuff of legend in the sense that
communications professionals should be studying
yesterday's Kayleigh McEnany press briefing.
Like the Zapruder film, to be perfectly frank, I'm
going to go through the dishonesty, the deception,
the mania of yesterday's press briefing. And just
as a reminder to lower everybody's blood pressure,
Caylee has seven weeks left. She is being replaced
by Joe Biden's choice. Jen Psaki, Jen Psaki is
very boring, very sober, very non scandalous.
So there's just seven weeks left of this
first question Caylee is asked. Donald Trump
has filed 40 lawsuits related to so-called
election fraud. They've all been thrown out.
The election has been certified in most states.
Does Donald Trump still think he can win?
Check out Caylee's answer or better said
her nonanswer of more than 40 cases that have
been brought by the president's legal team.
The majority have been denied or dismissed.
The election results have been certified
as full of the battleground states. The
president still thinks he has a path to win.
The president has said that he believes all legal
votes to be counted and all legal votes. Should
not be counted and in fact, the campaign is
pursuing that litigation, I can't get into the
details of that litigation here, but they still
do have active cases in Nevada and Wisconsin to
overturn the results when the verdict was
certified in these battleground states.
Again, the president is just looking for
every legal vote to be counted, and I will
leave it to the campaign to pursue their ends.
Can the president win an election that he lost?
And Cayley says, well, he thinks all legal votes
should be counted and go talk to the campaign,
which she is a member of. Remember that she is
a senior adviser to the campaign, but not today.
Today, she is White House press secretary. Every
question about some major scandal in a normal
administration, you would have an entire week of
press briefings where every question from every
reporter would be about one of these scandals. We
are in such an accelerated, scandal ridden world
that we are getting one question about the fake
voter fraud war Trump has been waging for a month.
Next question, one question about the
alleged cash for pardons scandal that is
being investigated and Trump's possible pardons
for his own children for Rudy Giuliani. Let's
listen to how Kelly handles that one question.
The president then spoke to her. General Bill Barr
says this comments came out yesterday.
I'm not aware if they've spoken. And I
know the attorney general was here yesterday for
a preplanned meeting with the chief of staff and
they discussed an array of issues. But I'm not
aware of the president has spoken to him directly.
The president conceded any preemptive pardons
to any of this. Has he talking and talking
to Attorney Giuliani about this?
I've heard no mention of any pardons
and any conversations I've had in the White
House other than the pardon of Lieutenant
General Michael Flynn, a three star general
who I've discussed from this podium before,
who had his life ruined. He was a valiant
hero who served his country both on the
battlefield and then came to work in government.
That's not former national security adviser
Michael Flynn. That's a three star general,
Michael Flynn, whose life was ruined. OK, so she
won't talk about the 40 election lawsuits and she
won't talk about pardons. Trump has been toying
with running again in 2024. Caylee is asked about
that. Will she talk about that? Let's take a look.
Sounds like he's planning to run again.
You know, if that's a fact, I haven't spoken to
him about that. Again, his campaign is pursuing
litigation. I would direct you to the campaign.
Now, of course, she is part of the campaign
that she's trying to redirect that question to.
But yesterday she wasn't wearing her campaign
hat. She was wearing her press secretary hat.
So she's not going to answer that. So lawsuit's
no answer. Pardon's no answer. Running again,
no answer. We're keeping track. She's
then asked again about evidence of fraud,
pointing out the reporter is that Bill Barr
said there is no such evidence. And again,
that's going to have to go to the campaign.
She tells us maybe the discrepancy is, you know,
you have members of the Trump campaign coming
forward and saying that there is hard evidence
of widespread voter fraud, enough to overturn the
outcome of the election. And then you have the
nation's top law enforcement officer, the attorney
general, saying if there is, he hasn't seen it.
Well, the attorney general was speaking to what
has come before his desk. And again, I'd point
you to the campaign for specific questions
on this, but I would just say generally they
are pursuing pursuing civil litigation, which,
in fact, the attorney general explicitly said
some of this is meant more for civil litigation,
which is what the campaign is currently pursuing.
Now, bear in mind, when she says civil litigation,
you can translate that to nothing that even
remotely has a shot at overturning a single
state, never mind the entire election.
That's how we should understand her saying there
is civil litigation. So then vaccination. Finally,
she will talk about vaccination to call the
vaccine the Trump vaccine that allows it to.
And we want 40 million doses by the end of the
year, which is a tremendous achievement, not just
to have gotten a vaccine in this time, but to have
produced 40 million in advance. It said having a
business plan is president the Trump vaccine.
And then vaccines actually came up again when
Caylee was asked, why has Donald Trump
been so MIA as the biggest surge ever
is happening right now? It's some examples of,
you know, lawmakers have been talking about it.
But I am curious, where is President Trump and and
offering public leadership on this topic of the
virus, especially as we've seen cases surge. We
haven't seen the president make any sort of public
comments or even tweets about this surge in cases.
So I'm curious what sort of examples you have?
Yeah, quite a bit. I mean, he's created the
greatest testing system in the world. He gave
a press conference about two weeks ago, I believe,
on the vaccine, which he has done at warp speed
because he's torn down bureaucratic barriers.
He's. Hard at work, he's done I don't know how
many coronavirus task force briefings from this
podium, but the work he's done speaks for itself,
the fact that now that case fatality rate in
this country is two percent, it was six percent.
And this is really important to understand. So the
first four questions we looked at, they were just
dishonest and sort of mischievous. Nonanswers
by Kayleigh McEnany here. I actually want to
talk about this, putting aside the hilarity of
Trump's press conference two weeks ago at which
he took no questions. But we're going to put that
aside. She says Trump has done vaccine development
at warp speed. It's the Trump vaccine. This just
isn't true. The reality is that these new vaccines
were developed on an MRI and a platform, and that
is a different way of developing vaccines than the
than the method that has traditionally been done,
which takes longer. And there are companies in
countries all over the world that have developed
MRSA vaccines that are all going to be ready very,
very soon. Some of them were part of operation
warp speed. Some of them were not. While in the
U.S. and somewhere in other countries, they all
were developed equally quickly. And in fact,
the biotech German vaccine, which then Pfizer
partnered with without taking operation warp speed
money that has already been approved for emergency
use in the U.K. So it's simply a type of vaccine
whose development is faster, don't fall for it.
And then Kayleigh McEnany is asked about threats
that are being faced by Georgia election workers.
We talked about this a couple of days ago. Donald
Trump keeps inspiring hostility towards election
workers. And Kaili pulls out a brilliant line,
which is there's no place for violence. And
however, take a look at the stupid questions.
Like Georgia officials have said, election workers
are facing threats because of the president's
false claims of winning the state
and his rhetoric around the election.
Does the president condemn the threats
against election workers or does he take
any responsibility for those? We condemn any
threats against anyone. There's no place for
violence. What I will say, though,
too, is that the president's lawyers,
they were dock's by a left organization, their
private information put out. So we're seeing that
happen to people on both sides of the argument.
And there's no place for that ever anywhere.
There is no place for violence. But
listen, one of Trump's lawyers was
Dock's. So what? So what? Two wrongs make
a right? What kind of answer is that even
from somebody speaking officially for the
White House? So we are getting down to the
end. Kayleigh McEnany has decided she's going down
with the ship or she is actively part of the the
group taking the ship down, continuing to
humiliate herself. Every interview, every
press briefing, truly stunning. And meanwhile,
we are still starting to see we are continuing
to see better said a little bit more fact checking
happening on Fox News. Let's talk about that next